friendship is
you get what you give you get what you
give
and if you are there for people you're
going to feel so good about having done
that
and then the the
the reciprocation effect which you
probably know very well
is so great in the world that anytime
you're kind to people
you build this incredible bond and then
what what are we at the end of the day
lex
besides a series of memories with the
people we love
that's all it is it's just a series of
memories
and moments it's just moments you ever
see blade runner
yes of course do you remember what
rucker harris says at the end
all of these memories gone like tears in
the rain yeah i mean that's our
existence
it just all goes away at some point it's
just these drops of rain each
each of those memories just like one
snowflake or one drop of rain
and they're all lost at some point but
they're here now
and that's why we have to be there for
each other that's why
i feel like what i do is so important in
this world
and i get such great meaning out of it
just being a friend just having these
conversations
what you're doing on your podcast just
talking to intelligent people
and spreading the word and the disciple
uh the gospel of what they're saying
and amplifying it you're inspiring so
many people every podcast you get 500
000 people a million people watch these
videos
and there's some kid in sri lanka or
some little girl in afghanistan who's
going to stumble upon this on youtube
and they're going to change the world in
the next century
because it's not just about america like
our story is almost over right like we
we were the story of the last two or
three hundred years i hope it keeps
going
but there's all these other places in
the world sao paulo and and africa
where people now have access to these
videos
and somebody will have this video and go
elon did it oh and that guy
jason was his friend and oh and then lex
does those interviews with the
oh yeah i could do it too your little
magical moment of love amidst the
suffering with elon
because you've talked about it you'll
have these ripple effects it's
fascinating to think about it
so weird to come in new entrepreneurs
being born
new yeah more love being put out there
in
uh more support through these rough
times when you're
people are trying to create new things i
mean that's a that's a beautiful thing
that's a beautiful i i'm
glad you think of friendship in this way
i'm
deeply uh grateful that you're loyal
every time you invest
you are here's the thing it cost you
nothing to make this investment either
the the amount of time it takes to be
bitter
or angry uh sitting at home uh
to be disappointed you could just
channel that same amount of energy into
being loyal
loving kind and there for people it just
only takes
the intention right the water is gonna
those emotions are gonna flow
right like sam would always tell me when
i was struggling in my life
and i talked to him he'd say you know
jason your brain is spewing all these
ideas
imagine you're standing sitting by a
river and the river is all your ideas
you are not a slave to any one of these
ideas they're just whipping by like each
of those little waves in the river
you can pick one of those ideas out and
look at it and examine it
and either keep it or throw it back in
the river and let it go
and i was like wow sam that was like of
my entire friendship with sam harris
that was like the one moment where i was
just like oh my god
all my life i've wondered about all
these thoughts in my head
insecurities you know imposter syndrome
like i didn't go to mit you know i'm not
the smartest guy
but somehow i made a career writing
little 50k
checks and now you know three million
dollar checks but whatever you know
little checks and
being a journalist and doing this little
podcast and it said it's added up to
something
and i kind of i'm proud of it i'm 50 and
i'm kind of proud of what i did
and i and i wake up every morning i
could retire and i say
i kind of like what i do i kind of like
having the conversation and writing the
check
and then being on somebody's team and i
got offered to be in these giant
mega funds and they said jason you're an
idiot you're investing 60 companies a
year
you know 500k at a time you put 30
million dollars a year to work
come work with us write 150 million
dollar check
and then you can go to aspen and
cabo and coachella and not work
but why are you doing all this work it's
like well the 50 million dollar check is
like it's like a formality it's just
like being an atm like the companies are
already huge by that time
i really want to meet the two people
with the idea i want to meet them in
year one
yes i want to meet them on day zero yeah
i want to be the guy who wrote the first
second or third check
yeah i want a guy with the 3 000th jack
the last check
that's [ __ ] boring and make that
basic human connection
and also be with me into the rough times
be with them with that first i mean the
first early successes i mean that's a
beautiful
so great when they when when when a
founder and that team get product market
fit
and you just know it's gonna work oh man
lex
it's when when com would email me and
they'd say
we had it you know the company's been
growing and we're not gonna go out of
business
but we added some sleep stuff and then
we added this other
function and uh we have a streak now and
uh we grew 10x in the last you know
three months
and uh we're good you know i was like ah
that's nice
it's real nice it's like it's a nice
feeling when you well because so many of
them die we talked about that j
curve early imagine it's like um
it's like all these baby turtles going
out to the ocean and the seagulls are
ripping them to shreds and then their
sharks are eating them but then like a
couple of the turtles make it
and they become wise old
hundred-year-old turtles yeah
you know and you're like yep i remember
when you catched
and like all of your brothers and
sisters were ripped to shreds by the
seagulls and you made it into the water
and then you made it out into the deep
water it's a pretty great feeling
i think there's no better way to end it
there it is
the talk of the cruelty of life that's
suffering that is life
and the love amidst the suffering jason
absolutely i've been a fan of yours for
a long time you're
one of the most special people in
silicon valley
thanks lex and maybe you'll also call me
in one of the rough times
oh yeah i'm sure there'll be many there
will be yeah you know
there's one expression nobody gets there
alone
nobody gets there alone and anybody who
thinks that they got there alone
is delusional and kidding themselves and
they will at some point wake up and
realize oh [ __ ]
there were a lot of people help me get
here i need to write a couple of
gratitude letters i got a gratitude
letter the other day from a friend of
mine
who i helped and it was one of the
you know about these gratitude letters
people are writing it turns out
martin seligman in um uh
was it authentic happiness anyway the
guy who really studied happiness and joy
turns out one of the greatest amplifiers
of joy in your life
is to thank somebody for doing something
for you and
somebody who i had helped just wrote me
a letter
and i got in christmas and i had the
stack of christmas cards and i hadn't
opened them
and it's the second week of january and
i was just getting to like the last act
and i opened it up and i almost missed
it this incredibly heartwarming letter
about how
meaningful like certain things i had
done to help along the way
and how he'd always always appreciated
my counsel and
i was just like well this happened 25
years ago
and you wrote this letter now and it
just hit me like a ton of bricks i was
just like wow you know
if you're hearing this there's probably
10 people who are really instrumental in
your lives
in your lives go ahead and call them on
the phone
write them an email or even better just
write a letter
and send it to them and just tell them
you're thankful
and let me tell you something the
amplification of joy in your life will
go 100x
100x when you tell somebody you love
them
and that you really appreciate them and
that what they did for you was magical
so just
and you can look it up gratitude
gratitude is like one of these
incredible forces
amen i'm grateful for being on the pod
i'm grateful
wasted all this time with me i love it
you